à redon où près de nantes en bretagne la
rave party est terminée il aura fallu
près de 24 heures et de violents
affrontements pour que les forces de
l'ordre parviennent à mettre fin à cette
fête illégale
quatorze personnes ont été blessées ces
images d'amateurs tourné hier semble
montrer qu'il ne s'agissait pas d'une
simple saisie mais plutôt d'une
destruction sévère en gazant et en
cassant un maximum de matériel alors
était ce légal il était pas envisageable
de saisir le matériel que le cas c'est
parce que l'épaule il a été neutralisé
ou café il a été neutralisé
saint nicolas de bourgueil en quelques
minutes une ligne tornade balaie tout
sur son passage dans le centre du
village
le clocher de l'église est arraché une
partie de la toiture envolée
voyez aussi ces images alfortville en
région parisienne avec de gros dégâts
voici aussi toutes ces images vues sur
les réseaux sociaux
il n'y a pas de blessé mais c'est tout à
fait impressionnant orage de grêle aussi
en dordogne hier soir c'est vers 21h que
le ciel se met à gronder à reims et sa
périphérie
c'est terrifiant lattès les témoins
stupéfait devant l'avancée de l'orage le
centre-ville de reims inondé ya des gens
qui ne comprennent même plus la
dimension de l'humour ce papa sitôt la
par exemple quand je suis dit si
effectivement un groupe fasciste appels
à tuer aujourd'hui que mélenchon c'est
condamnable
je regarde la vidéo mais j'ai vu que
c'est de l'humour alors on n'aime pas on
aime ou n'aime pas c'est comme on veut
mais je veux dire que quand on n'est pas
capable de comprendre la dimension
humoristique et qu'on transfère pied de
la lettre en disant c'est un fasciste
qui veut ma peau
à 8h20 l'ancien premier ministre edouard
philippe s'est présenté dans un bureau
de vote au havre dans la foulée et de
l'autre côté de la france le président
sortant à la région provence alpes côte
d'azur
renaud muselier est le premier à voter à
marseille avant jean luc mélenchon
quelques heures plus tard emmanuel
macron lui s'apprête vous voyez à voter
au touquet le président qui a pris le
temps qui prend le temps en ce moment de
saluer les curieux à l'extérieur de ce
bureau de vote donc accompagné de son
épouse s'est rendu à 11h dans les ions
de saint quentin
une demi-heure plus tard c'est au tour
de marine le pen à hénin beaumont
du côté du gouvernement c'est le garde
des sceaux et tête de liste dans le
pas-de-calais pour les régionales eric
dupond moretti qui ouvre la voie
treize ministres sont engagé
personnellement dans cette bataille
un an de la présidentielle ces
régionales seront riches d'enseignements
tous les ministres qui sont en
permanence vous regardez les
informations et tous les jours une
information continue il ya toujours un
ministre est sorti
qu'est ce qu'ils font là ils s'en vont
couper des rubans ils sauront dire des
sottises de bêtises et bien c'est un
début de scrutin poussif nathalie vous
l'avez dit 12,22 % de participation au
1er tour à midi je tiens à remercier
l'ensemble des des élus de le des
services municipaux des services de
l'état qui permette que ces opérations
de vote ce thème dans les bonnes
conditions compris sanitaire
c'est le fait politique majeur c'est de
voir qu'à 17 heures ce chiffre 26 72% de
participation les urnes pour l'instant
sont désertés thierry mariani arrive en
tête avec 34 bien vu lever pour cent des
voix devant le président sortant
l air renaud muselier et bien c'est le
candidat ait l'air laurent wauquiez qui
est très largement en tête avec 45 de
lui pour cent et voici une estimation
pour les hauts de france xavier bertrand
arrive très largement en tête à 44%
nous avons déchiré pour les briser les
mâchoires du front national leur
démagogie leur proposition stérile leur
intolérance tout ce qui divise et tout
ce qu'est le front national l'estimation
de participation selon harris
interactive vous le voyez elle est de 31
4%